foreign
[Music]
I have talked about
how much I despise Kevin Nash
for those of you that don't remember
Kevin Nash uh pro wrestler his son died
26 years old he had a seizure and a
heart attack strange
strange all these young people just
dropping dead so [ __ ] strange so
anyway
um
Tristan Nash 26 years old he dies and
Kevin has been like we're trying to quit
drinking cold turkey
and uh you know I found out people can
have seizures when they're trying to
quit drinking it was so gorgeous
looks like is he glamming me
um
like most people with cognitive
dissonance he just doesn't want to
connect the dots
he doesn't want to connect the dots he'd
rather believe that his son died trying
to quit drinking which at 26 years old
unless you're a [ __ ] again I've
talked about this before in order to
need the medication to wean off alcohol
like very rarely does a 26 year old
go in for any kind of medical opinion
about quitting drinking and have a
doctor go yeah we need to put you on all
this [ __ ]
most of the time a doctor will go you're
26 and unless you've been [ __ ] living
like leaving Las Vegas style every day
of your life since you were 15. it's
very doubtful you're gonna [ __ ] have
the seizure
um
seizure and a heart attack
[ __ ] weird
um so ever since then
Kevin's been
we talked about the uh the CL I'll play
the clip first because this clip
infuriated me this clip [ __ ]
infuriated me
um
was it this one I think it's this
episode you know when he talks about
this is it yeah can we ghost
do you um when you g-ring or something
like that but it was it was like it had
one one but the other thing was his uh
his benzos
uh you know to make sure that he didn't
seize and everything else oh and by the
way try to dmca me [ __ ] Sean Oliver
try to DM see Amy Chris Kevin Nash
I don't [ __ ] play those games you I
know you guys think that you're doing
this whole like written authorization
you can it's fair use [ __ ] this is
transformative
your son died it's newsworthy
like this wasn't you know we we didn't
WebMD this you know it's like this was
you handled it yeah it's like come on
and then the other thing is well was he
vaccinated
well geez what if you read my Twitter it
says you know Central is Democrat so
what do you think I mean I'm probably
one of the few people on this planet
that have five shots
I mean I got I got both boosters and I
just got this last
garbage whatever the hell at this point
and I'm gonna I'll go get the flu shot
now it's just like I just do it now
because
it's just
who cares
so this [ __ ] guy
who basically killed this kid
um
now because he's nihilistic now because
he he's saying just [ __ ] it dude who
cares anymore his plan you heard him I
played the clip when he's like my son
[ __ ] he knew man he knew this world
sucks man oh but she just checked out
man no he died because you know
you wanted to you know get shots because
[ __ ] it dude right who cares
I'm just gonna I'm gonna be a [ __ ]
I'm gonna be one of the Tuskegee gearmen
man I'm gonna have everybody just I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] I'm just gonna be a
lab rat for Pfizer man because like I
don't know cause like oh who [ __ ]
cares man all that [ __ ] moderna
experiment on my dead kid right [ __ ] it
dude [ __ ] it dude
this guy [ __ ] sucks
this guy [ __ ]
socks
we all know it
who the [ __ ] says something like that
like
look
it'd be one thing if you know I know
that there are some people out there who
really just believe in facts and that's
fine
there are some people out there that
can say I'm getting this and here's why
and bing bong bing and these are my
ideas this is my reasoning and this is
because I think it'll do this but when
you're like I'll get all the boosters
man because [ __ ] it bro who cares dude
what an irresponsible [ __ ] message to
put out there anyway if you didn't think
Kevin Nash was scummy already
I need a drink before I show this to you
guys
we sure need one daddy magic good to see
you pal
so Kevin's best episode of click this
with Sean Oliver
It's the episode where son died
um I didn't he
even brought up the fact that um
I don't think did I play that clip maybe
I need to go back to the clip that um
through the thousands of well wishes
just keep going he just really gotta
just yeah and the thing is too that it's
just like
there were so many people that
um
some of the the things that oh here it
is and uh there was a lot of you know
there's a couple of things you know that
here and there that was like yeah if I
could do that over I would if I could do
that over it but but then again then it
wouldn't have been it would have been
organic and it wouldn't have been you
know would have been real yeah we just
we we had nothing we didn't know whether
that show was going to last a minute two
minutes
and
so this is this is the one of the one of
the funny things I thought is
we kiddingly talked about before we went
out like oh this is going to be
you know great to drop that that blue
shoe which always got tea to laugh you
know the Bluetooth always if T always
laughed he always would chuckle about
like you know he's like Dad did you ever
think you'd be pushing you know
yeah
erectile dysfunction I said was that
right we're not it's not erectile
dysfunction it's just you know it's just
sharpening your pencil that's it giving
you a rager yeah and um so you started
earlier in the show to do like a a mock
when then you didn't finish it and I
never remembered you
actually doing the spa you gave it to me
you gave it to me I know with the norm
the reason you don't remember the spot
you [ __ ] CTE [ __ ]
you old drunk idiot with a dead son
is because Sean pre-records the [ __ ]
live reads and inserts them into the
episode you dumb [ __ ]
he thought that like Sean Oliver just
started doing a live reading for now
I'll tell you right now man
what bothered me was that he really did
put
a bunch of AD reads
in an episode
about his dead son
they did like three or four live reads
which is unbelievable like it's just so
scummy that they she that he even did
his podcast like the day after his son
died and then did blue true ad reads is
just beyond me
it gets better oh it gets well not
better I'd say it gets worse
get ready
the latest video from the click this
channel
is titled
Tristan Nash wanted this Channel at 100k
Tristan Nash wanted this channel
at 100K my son died subscribed to me my
son would have wanted it this way
foreign
your dead son glammed you
and now you [ __ ] ghoulishly telling
people that TR like
couldn't imagine
God forbid something happened to Royce
and he died
and
I just do a show the next day and bang
out some live reads
and then go like hey guys just you know
Royce would have really wanted you guys
to subscribe and for me to make more
money than ever
he would have wanted it that way and you
know what if Royce died he would want me
to make a lot of money I can't see Roy's
you know being in the afterlife being
like that son of a [ __ ] is making money
but my God but don't invoke my dead name
to make it I like that's so dirty bro
it's this [ __ ] Sun
now I haven't watched this yet
but holy [ __ ]
we're about to watch this
um hang on son let me what was when did
when did your dumb kid die
um
it was
a couple weeks ago
when are we getting the [ __ ] when are
we getting the Kevin scampoli [ __ ]
Masterpiece when are we getting that
back
I need Kevin I keep I need the Kevin
Nash's dead Sun bit that was some of the
wildest [ __ ] radio I've ever heard in
my life that was one of the craziest
shows ever you [ __ ] are you glamming
me
you trying to [ __ ] your dead vampire son
you sick [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] so anyway uh I want to see this
I want to see this uh by the way
suspicious 444 I got a 444 that's four
minutes 44 seconds on this video no when
I walked in here if because that one was
you know like I said it was
it was it was bottomed out and this one
um
it's you know like the funny thing is
and
like T when he found out I don't know if
Steve told him or I don't know who took
that one who oh so the fact that he's
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] about his
dead son I want to really I really want
to drive this point home so that you
people understand just how [ __ ] up
this is
Kevin Nash is how old is he now
Kevin Nash is 63 years old
his wife
is younger
than him
but too old to be having kids right he's
63 his wife is
five years
younger than me
so she's like 34. okay so they could try
again I guess maybe
um
1988 really
oh no they married in 1988. whoa no
buddy so she's not my she's not five
years younger than me she married him in
1988 so they're both old
um your womb is a [ __ ] Factory now
your wife's room is a [ __ ] Factory
um you're getting up there in years you
could probably still like
you know skeet skeet you could probably
steal Larry King a kid out with your
sperm
um
okay
but like your wife's got a [ __ ]
Factory in her womb now so
um your best chance now is to knock up
like an Amber Heard or something but
like it's
for you to have a son for you to have a
one
one single solitary child
and for him to be a son
and for him to be a tall
you know normal looking guy who carries
your name he's your namesake he's your
heir
and then you lose that
and your [ __ ] first concern is
getting your channel to 100K Subs let me
tell you something if if I died or if
Royce died right if the other guy
started getting phone calls or emails or
text messages within 48 hours from
people from let's say locals or rumble
or our ad guys or you know what I mean
like if somebody was actually going like
hey guys like I know Royce is dead but
like you know you guys still do well
with Samad reads and like I was just
wondering you know if you could let me
know like when you're going back on the
air like that's one of those where I
would call you back and go what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you what kind of sick
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that you don't
think when I come back I'm not going to
be able to see like I can milk some
sympathy when I come back I'll sell some
[ __ ] boner pills you [ __ ] ghoul
but for now how about you [ __ ] off how
about everyone shut the [ __ ] up for a
week
how about we [ __ ] bury the dead how
about we [ __ ] you know what I mean
Comfort people who are mourning right
now you piece of guard you want me to
get on and do you a little hey check out
my bookie go [ __ ] yourself like that's
one of those we want me or the other one
would be [ __ ]
threatening to kick the [ __ ] out of our
ad guys I will [ __ ] you up if I see you
in the streets homie on site
AEG luck Royce is dead subscribe to
Jake's minture he loved it and you all
should love it
Jesus dude the [ __ ]
it's your son it's your dead vampire
Glam son
I'm I'm taking somebody like I'm I'm
taking the
uh the Yeoman uh portion of his uh
his uh urn
okay this is sick talking about your
son's urn while you show your social
blade
this is a level of D this is the guy
that goes you're [ __ ] Alex Jones that
guy's a real [ __ ] psychopath hey you
know what Nash you know what Alex Jones
has a [ __ ] living son
it's great shape actually too
do you know what else he has Kevin other
children
and a new young hot wife
and you know what yeah he lost a billion
dollars his company whatever but he's
not gonna Alex Jones is never gonna be
living in the gutter you [ __ ]
but you know what Alex Jones has
a son named Rex who's going to carry on
his [ __ ] Legacy to some degree
Alex isn't out there going oh my son
died check out my social blade I need
more Twitter followers folks tell Elon
Musk I need my Twitter back it's like
you go [ __ ] mourn your son
um
this is so [ __ ] dark I gotta it's
like when I'm looking at my son's urn
you guys should check it out man we need
subs
his earned
all right well we're all right we're
more than half oh good old Haiti
but uh we're uh
and I I you know I'm taking I'm taking a
a nice size urn of him down here with me
and it's going to be on the into my into
my my table here as I work and you know
hopefully we can uh
can get a hundred thousand people to
subscribe if if nothing else just for
tea
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what I hope you get demonetized
I hope you get [ __ ] demonetized Nash
week and you you listen we I know how
many people listen to this show and it's
people they're just not clicking
subscribe so all you guys listening
hundreds of thousands of people click
subscribe so we can get that uh yes it
doesn't make us any it doesn't make us
any money it just gives us a [ __ ]
plaque and I'm gonna have to pay for one
anyway so I actually I'm gonna I'm
losing on this in the rent yeah I lose
it on this deal but I know that somebody
somebody looking from upstairs would be
like ah boy Dad we're not to drop the
[ __ ] ball sorry
all right and
this week we did not forget yeah my son
would have been looking down on me going
man using me as a [ __ ] just using me
as a [ __ ] pity party to get
subscribers on YouTube my death that I
died taking a shot that I grew up in
your house and grew up with your
opinions and I agreed with you about the
shot and I thought it was a good idea
now I'm dead at 26.
I'm so proud of my dad for not dropping
the ball listen like I said if I died
and Royce was using me to like don't get
me wrong if anybody's lightly using me
to show
I would go all right that's my man right
like it it's there's a difference
between somebody like a month later
like you know if I died I would expect
Royce to at least take a week off Jesus
Christ be [ __ ] pissed if he just like
came back the next day take a week off
but then come back after a week go back
to normal [ __ ] um
go back to your normal routine and ease
back into it and look is it forgivable
if you're doing a live read that you
were gonna do anyway and you're like
yeah guys check out mybookie.ag by the
way man you know I know Royce right now
and I know merch is looking down right
now and he would tell you you want to
use that promo code
Marsh would have wanted it that way then
it's funny
then it's funny but it's not you know
like the couple days later it's merch
would have wanted that like it's one
thing to jokingly go like guys seriously
make sure you click that Bell merch
wanted it man may he rest that's funny
but when you make a clip entitled merch
would want you to be here at 100K what
are we doing boys
that's a little insane right like that's
beyond [ __ ] what are we doing here
boys what are we doing here Boys what
Happened Kevin you got a little cocky
huh little cocky in a costume
everybody's booing you go
we don't like you now
you killed your son now he's a vampire
and he's clamming him
hitting
God damn it
I'll tell you what's not hitting this
thing
you're out there hitting [ __ ] the
whole [ __ ] show with copyright
strikes
so you can use your dead kid for [ __ ]
clicks but he's not allowed to make fun
of your dead kid for [ __ ] glitch
foreign
did this start
when the old man
oh yeah like I'll use my dead kid I'm a
piece of [ __ ] but you can't use my dead
kid for clicks Kevin it's worse that
you're using your dead kid for clicks
Kevin scampoli using your dead kid for
clicks that makes sense it's not his
[ __ ] kid
okay so that was uh we're up to 15 here
let's do these coffees real quick get
caught up uh actually we'll finish with
Nashville while I'm lining us up I'm
certainly not wearing spikes but I'm
bleeding from my urethra right now
so maybe you tried to get it in that uh
iced tea container yeah let's just tried
exacto knife slipped well we should tell
everyone that click this is a production
of Butch and Sundance media produced an
association with podcast heat created by
Kevin Nash Tristan what the [ __ ] is this
ew are you playing this this has got to
be one of his songs It's gotta be his
son's band oh I bet it's his son's band
playing what was that they just potted
it in all out and [ __ ]
I sneezed what the [ __ ] was that
that's his son's [ __ ] band I'll bet
um what was this band's car [ __ ] um
what's the name of his band the builders
the builders uh
uh big big famous band you know what's
funny too he was [ __ ] 2019 his his
son started a band called the builders
Kevin Nash is his [ __ ] dad you guys
couldn't get more than 143 followers and
they were retweeting wrestling like they
were trying to get in that algorithm
God this is [ __ ]
yeah this has got to be his band right
It's gotta be his band
emphasize myself watch it watch later
toss this in it's terrible so maybe you
tried to get it in that uh iced tea
container yeah let's just try it watch
watch how it just exacto knife slipped
well we should tell everyone that click
this is a production of Butch and
Sundance media producing association
with podcast heat created by Kevin Nash
Tristan Nash ashaw of her producer Steve
Kaufman graphics and social media by
Dominic D'Angelo title sequence and oh
you don't have to read the Tristan Nash
credit anymore he's [ __ ] dead
Video Edit by Wesley Burleson theme song
by Dale Oliver technical research by
Kevin have by Tristan Nash copy imagine
that technical research by Kevin Nash
copyright 2022 Butch and Sundance media
can't do me a favor ask your son if we
can do another
hey T can we do another one
what's that hold up I can't hear
it says depends on how close we get to
100K
yes
oh
we want a taste of the title
what happened to us
what happened to us
uh Mike says no Kevin said he wanted his
name and the credits two shows ago all
right well but again you put in the
credit he's [ __ ] dead it's a waste of
a credit I would waste I like I saved my
advertise like that would be like
advertising for a company that that's
out of business
[ __ ] are you doing I almost saved my
time I'm gonna talk about people that
are alive I like people who didn't die
from the max
in your hands
[Music]
wait a minute you're wow
this is [ __ ] sick so it's his son's
shitty band the sun shitty music their
shitty font
and then they're doing this for tea man
just like like this is
oh wow
[Music]
meanwhile meanwhile [ __ ] scampoli's
the worst person ever because he made
fun of you for your dead son glamming
you
He's the bad guy
oh my God yo Mr Depot money that that is
the [ __ ] that's the font for it
that was that new It remake font
oh God everything about your show sucks
you know what I was looking forward to
click this I really was I enjoyed Sean
Oliver and Kevin Nash they used to have
a good thing going do you know what
happened they did the same [ __ ] PR
here's the thing we liked Kevin Nash we
liked Sean Oliver when they did you know
you shoot they did okay fake
commentaries because it was once in a
while it was an event when it happened
but what happened just like H3
you [ __ ] went no we're doing
this twice a week
and the problem is
is that as people found out over time
it's very hard
it's horde
to do a Daily Show it's hard to do two
shows a week some people just don't have
enough to talk about and that's why
you're seeing click this talk about
Trump and Alex Jones and they're trying
to ride the algorithm nobody cares they
want to hear [ __ ] stories about Scott
Hall
Shawn Michaels that's all they care
about
Sean Oliver got pissed that people
started thinking that oh click this
they're going to try to say it's just a
wrestling show that's what we want to
hear you and Kevin talk about [ __ ]
wrestling not your dead son trying to
molest you and not you [ __ ] not your
opinions on Trump and not your [ __ ]
[ __ ] not your son's bad music
we want you to talk about wrestling so
the [ __ ] balls on these two everybody
was looking forward to this but now now
you're doing the H3 thing holy [ __ ] how
do we stay entered and you know I don't
get it right because
for people it'll tell us like oh yeah
you guys you and Royce you just do a
podcast that's not work
it's like okay then tell me why when
Hassan [ __ ] and and Ethan Klein tried
to do a show that was a cash grab
together nobody liked it because they
had no chemistry and they had nothing to
talk about they had no original takes on
anything nobody cared
foreign
thing people thought Ethan was funny did
his quirky little videos and his little
[ __ ] or whatever and then all of a
sudden he wanted to start doing it no
the money isn't streaming you gotta
stream every day
to make the money
and I'll admit look I do this for money
I did I do this to make a living I want
to make money
right
um
which reminds me I never post I never
promoted the uh the thing tonight
because I went on a rant about the
entertainment center uh you know revenge
of assist.com Slash nightwave I love
money
you want to donate donate you don't find
don't who cares but
you guys have watched me do this show
for years some of you and
you've seen me I I I try to give the
same level of show I've had shows where
I made a bunch of money and it wasn't
even a good show I've had shows that I
made almost no money and it was a
goddamn instant classic Hall of Fame
shows
um
so there's nothing wrong with coming in
and doing the grind or whatever but man
some of these guys like like click this
and H3 they don't even try to entertain
Their audience
they're just like wow we're famous and
you [ __ ] better just show up because
we're here
that's what they expect no we're famous
we already did we already entertained
you [ __ ] for years you just oh
you need to just come in here and pay
your dues because I'm Kevin Nash my
[ __ ] son's dad my my dead son's Glam
and me so [ __ ] gorgeous
but it's like me and Royce do a show we
actually bring some [ __ ] Heat
I mean you know we try to anyway they're
not all [ __ ] gems but for the most
part I try to bring the heaters
foreign
they do show up yeah well you know who
ain't showing up anymore Tristan Nash
because he's [ __ ] dead
[ __ ] you Kevin Nash
I hope you have another I hope you have
a [ __ ] another bit I hope you go find
some I hope you divorce your wife
because because you decided that she's
she's old and eggless and you wanted to
you know what no Tristan's dead I want
to carry on my legacy and I hope you
leave your wife for like a young piece
of ass and I hope she's like some hot
[ __ ] 30 year old and I hope you knock
her up and I hope she miscarries and
then I hope you [ __ ] she divorces you
and takes all your money
that's what I wish for you
how about that Kev
and if you're asking man why would you
shut on Kevin Nash because at this point
it's like you know like just who cares
man
who cares man
[ __ ] [ __ ]